Good evening to the round on the field.
Uh.
I would like to thank NDR for having the opportunity
today to present my position on this difficult topic.
According to a recent survey by NDR,
80 percent of respondents in Lower Saxony
call for a change in asylum and refugee policy,
the Alternative for Germany.
The AfD has been making these demands since 2,015.
Many communities have now been completely abandoned by governments,
completely by the flood of non-cultural migrants.
The AfD has consistently recognized the negative
consequences of illegal migration for our social systems and security.
Liberal countries like Australia,
Canada,
we heard that.
Denmark and Sweden pulled the ripcord years ago
and are now pursuing a restrictive migration policy.
The AfD's demands have been known for a long
time and are increasingly being adopted by others.
1st We call for the reduction of the highly
attractive pool factors such as civic income,
unlimited toleration and family that have entered illegally.
2nd Permanent and complete control of
national borders and expulsion of illegal migrants,
and 3rd Consistent repatriation of all rejected asylum
seekers to home countries or safe third countries
Should legal adaptations be necessary for the above measures.
We are at our disposal as the AfD.
I thank you for your attention.